and this is a Fox News Alert this Friday
night welcome to Hannity we have three
major breaking news stories at this hour
chaotic protest breaking out all across
the world today after one former Hamas
leader called for an international day
of jihad our very own Sarah Carter was
in Time Square covering what was a
massive protest uh there by the way
things are still going on in New York
City uh earlier today things got tense
where she was here is a quick preview
do you care about the babies that were
beheaded the babies they were never
beheaded that was a madeup story not
true it's show me the pictures now so
what about show me the pictur you're a
lion full of you're full
of just go to the just go to exen the
prime minister of Israel's account and
you'll see the pictures plus this is
huge news House of Republicans they're
one step closer to finding their next
speaker after nominating Ohio
Congressman Jim Jordan during today's
conference meeting and it is now time
for Republicans to come together get a
new speaker with the new war breaking
out in the Middle East and our closest
Ally there Israel involved this is not a
time for Republicans to be weak they
need to be United they need to put aside
their infighting and they need to move
forward and reopen the people's house
Jim Jordan would make a great speaker
we'll have more on all of that coming up
later but first
tonight another Fox News Alert it is
9:00 p.m. on the East Coast it is 6:00
p.m. on the west coast it is 4:00 a.m.
in Gaza as you can see live pictures now
what is going on there earlier today
Israeli Defense Forces confirmed to Fox
News they have in fact entered Gaza for
localized raids and they have begun the
process of now clearing out Hamas so
that they can no longer use Hamas at
Gaza as a launching ground to bomb
nearby Israeli cities last night right
here on this program Israel continued
their retaliatory air strikes against
targeted Hamas locations in Gaza we have
reports now indicating they struck at
least
750 Hamas military targets just
overnight last night most of that
happened during the two hours we were on
the air and as we reported last night
Israel issued a warning to civilians in
Northern Gaza and to the UN giving them
24 hours to evacuate and that window has
now a officially passed according to a
recent report from Fox News War
correspondent Trey yingst earlier today
some Hamas members are actually
preventing civilians from actually
leaving they want to leave they want to
listen to the warning but yet Hamas
wants them to be human Shields why do
they think that will protect them
another sick side of Hamas an evil side
of Hamas take a look we're getting some
new reporting from the Gaza Strip a
diplomatic Source telling Fox news today
that Hamas is preventing civilians
inside homes and you just heard that
explosion in the distance they are
continuing air strikes at this hour in
Gaza but this Source telling Fox News
that Hamas is preventing civilians from
leaving their homes after they announc
that there will be an air strike there
the Israelis have a way of informing
civilians telling them to leave and then
destroying homes that are linked to
Hamas or have some sort of relevant
Target for the Israelis and a source
inside Gaza confirming that information
to us
and now with estimates now putting the
total number of Palestinian refugees at
over 1 million the question is where do
they go Egypt is fa facing mounting
pressure to open its borders to civilian
refugees uh so far they have refused so
why won't they open their borders at
least to women and children maybe
seeking Refuge well you do have to
remember one thing and that is as we
have been showing you this week children
in Palestine they are radicalized from
from birth they are indoctrinated as
young children uh to have hatred of
quote the Jews from the earliest stages
of Life they are taught to hate and
quote kill Jews here's a reminder of
their disturbing programming these are
cartoons for for children shows for
[Music]
children
well we've come a long way from Bugs
Bunny and Tweety bird uh here is what
needs to happen with Israel as of
tonight Gaza can no longer be used as a
launching ground for Hamas to fire
Rockets into neighboring very near very
geographically close Israeli cities
Israel must end this as a staging ground
for Hamas as Gaza is so close to Israel
geographically what happens next is
there will be full-on War conflict
shootings bombings exchanges people on
both sides are going to die sadly
innocent people will die our prayers
tonight are with the Israelis that now
have to defend once again their Homeland
and the innocent you know human beings
that are used as Shields so that Hamas
could well try and and protect their own
lives you know being the cowards that
they really are because you know what
but all of this could stop all of it
could end right now if Hamas the terror
group would lay down their weapons lay
down their arms stop using human Shields
but don't hold your breath why would you
expect a terrorist group with such vile
hatred in their hearts to ever have any
empathy any awareness of the Carnage
that they are causing this is a group
that is founded in their principle their
Charter with the idea that Israel must
be destroyed they use hospitals as human
Shields along with schools and now
according to reports they plan on using
Israeli civilian hostages as human
Shields they're already using
Palestinian civilians trying to leave
his human Shields why just to advance
their radical uh ideology if Hamas laid
down their arms today nobody would die
nobody needs to Die the inevitable
senseless loss of life it could all be
prevented Israel could enter Gaza they
can prevent future attacks from
happening on their country but if Israel
were to lay down their arms as some on
the radical left have called for well it
would be uh and not just a ceasefire
Israel would cease to exist the brutal
Hamas terrorists who have no regard for
human life or Hezbollah uh to the other
side of Israel would completely destroy
Israel they have said so they have
plotted they have planned they have
schemed to do so and meanwhile today
Iran's foreign minister warned Israel of
new fronts opening up in the war if they
don't stop their retaliatory strikes
meaning defend themselves which Iran is
now referring to as war crimes that's a
bit of a joke a sick joke now these
strikes wouldn't have been necessary if
Hamas hadn't killed 1300 plus Israelis
and didn't rape and burn and behead even
little babies and women while apparently
carrying Isis flags as they commit these
brutal violent repulsive acts now the
comments from Iran's foreign minister
came during a visit to Lebanon in which
he met with the head of the Iranian back
terrorist group Hezbollah which has been
firing Rockets into Israel all week and
earlier today Hezbollah claimed credit
for attacks on Israel's military post
along the Lebanon border and in a
desperate and frankly pathetic attempt
to swing public approval Hamas is now
claiming 13 hostages were killed by
Israeli air strikes but take everything
they say with a grain of salt these are
terrorists they are killers they are
liars their words are worthless but the
glial mob and the media they might have
eventually start going along with it and
stop advancing their propaganda like
they did during today's day of jihad
somehow over the course of the last 24
hours 48 hours Outlets uh they stopped
calling it what Hamas meant it to be
Hamas wanted it to be a day of jihad and
then all these news outlets said um well
no this is a day of rage instead of the
day of G Jihad now Jihad by the way
which means holy war now as angry and
violent protests are breaking out all
across the world now protests in the
United States have gone on all week with
some of the worst Pro Palestinian pramas
protest taking place across our college
campuses how repugnant it is to watch uh
ivy league institutions like Yale and
Harvard look at Harvard you know take
take a look at that gut-wrenching video
of two Jewish women confronting
protesters at the University of
Washington this young girl and her it it
pretty much says it all it's
inexplicable they want to kill us they
want to destroy us they want to murder
us